and of course felicity oscar nominated
for playing stephen hawking's wife
you've been in this situation you've
been with this woman you're portraying
so do you have a similar experience or
was it well it's quite interesting it's
it's um it's important that you get the
almost the person's permission
that you feel like they
you kind of go through a little bit i
felt with playing jane there's a little
bit of a trial period where we went
eddie and i went and and spent some time
with her and and had dinner with her and
and it did feel like it was much harder
than any audition we'd ever done in our
entire life because you sort of feel you
know you need the nod of approval from
from the person at the at the end that
they you know they could say oh they're
giving their lives up they're giving
their lives up to to for everyone to see
so you sort of want to somehow there'll
be an exchange that you're going to
you're going to look after their their
story in some way which i imagine
exactly but and eddie's been talked
about uh you know meeting stephen
hawking and sort of hanging out and you
sort of hung out as well didn't you we
did we did he um stephen came to set and
we were we were very very nervous and we
you know sort of tried to do our you
know doing going over the lines and
wanted to do our best version of the
take and doing these performances and um
and then
afterwards then they and they shouted
cut and we thought you know we're just
anxiously waiting for what stephen would
think and he said um
he wrote down and we were kind of
anxiously waiting and he said
would felicity please be able to come
and give me a kiss
hello
and what's what's wonderful about steven
is he doesn't take himself seriously at
all he just i'd say he was quite serious
i don't think there was a joke in that
note
i was like get her over here make her
kiss me
i was hoping he meant in a kind of sort
of you know evan killer maybe
let's hope that yeah
[Music]
you